prisoner phd a drug dealer
father each of these words conjures up
a different picture none of them tells
you
exactly who someone is my name is
stephen acquired kevin tuskey i'm a phd
candidate and i'm a lecturer in
criminology
with the open university i work with
students
in prison i love what i do
it feels deeply personal to me because
i used to be a prisoner too all of these
labels
have been mine
so growing up life was tough my father
died in the car
crash when i was a teenager and that hit
me really hard
i didn't see the world as a meritocracy
i
had to grab what i could but being sent
to prison
for dealing drugs was a shock i was
sentenced to 16 years
for the first three months inside i
didn't speak to anyone
eventually i started working in the
kitchens
as people got to know me i was
eventually assessed for
my educational potential and encouraged
after that assessment to
enroll at the open university but the
most
difficult barrier was actually inside of
me
i'd let school with no qualifications
nothing
i was scared of my future and i decided
to try
my day job working in the kitchens
having a surgery
meant that i had to study at night so i
had to study my toilet while myself in
snowboarder so when i finished my first
module
it gave me hope and it gave me something
i could
focus on that was not going back now
other prisoners and girls kept asking me
why i was wasting my time
studying wouldn't matter with my
criminal record
i thought i was changing i discovered i
loved learning and that was enough to
keep me going
i served eight years of my 16-year
sentence by the time i left
prison i had completed my first degree i
had
also completed two further degrees at
master's level so after i was released i
got a job working with
students in prisons not in spite of who
i was but because of it
it had to describe how i felt the first
time i went back to prison
as a lecturer and the governors come
down and shoot my hand
what i want people to know is that i'm
not different or special
anybody can do this almost half of all
prisoners
have left school without achieving any
formal qualification
i know how that feels and it had a
massive impact on my confidence
but that does not mean that you're not
able to learn
everyone has the potential and the power
to change
i've seen it and i've lived it there was
released in churchill who said
there is treasure if you can only find
it
in the heart of every man what do we
want from our prisons
is the primary goal of prisons punished
or to help
find a different path the policy isn't
coherent you see
research shows that education does
reduce
reoffending it allows former prisoners
to make different choices so when i sit
with prisoners
i say to them i was in shoes but i am
now
released outside got a good job
got a good life with my family
had i met somebody like me when i was
younger
i thinks might have been very different
no one believed in me
i didn't believe in myself either it's
taken
two decades to get here and this is only
the beginning
the word prisoner is just a label i
found freedom within my own mind you
need to remember
that you have the capacity to learn you
have the capacity to change your life
there is treasure within each and every
one of us
you